hi guillaume i heard you help companies
move to the cloud
hi martin yes i work for accenture with
the google cloud partner company
we help businesses move to the cloud
including serverless
i have helped many businesses make the
move
great
could you tell us what you've learned
about successful cloud migrations yeah i
will be happy to
[Music]
all right so in your experience what
kind of businesses want to move to the
cloud oh most of them they don't want to
buy more servers for their data centers
servers in the cloud are cheaper when
you take into account all the management
cost
plugs in servers unplug the last one
destroy the disk and show the site
physical security stephanie has released
a great video on the google cloud data
center security
and it's harder than you think
oh yeah that's a really good video you
know i remember putting servers into
racks for one of my startups back in the
day
our data center was in san mateo
california yes that's fine but you may
need one that's hunter in europe one in
asia one north america and so on
lawsub data storage may force you to do
that
or you may want your servers close to
your users to reduce latency
this means
it's hard to go global
with cloud you get that for free
but there are two challenges in my
experience when a business migrate to
the cloud they face three major
challenges
oh what are those three challenges
first of all security
the security teams in most businesses
want to make sure that their internal
system cannot be accessed from the
public internet
that's usually how their existing
on-prem environment works
okay that sounds reasonable
how do you help them with that
two things
first i like to remove the virtual
machine's public ips and to put all the
vms behind load balancers
so the vms
are not directly visible to the public
internet
second
i help them set up organization policies
this means that new vms cannot get
public ips without an exception to the
policy
i see
so that's for virtual machines what
about security for serverless
serverless is a new party
many serverless products have public ips
by default
they base their security on claddiam
instead
and many security teams are
uncomfortable with that
and how do you deal with that oh i
explained this to party and how we can
help them implement zero trust
this means that you don't trust incoming
traffic just because it's from your
internal network
you check all traffic and trust the
identity in addition of the origin
so you said there were three challenges
uh what's the second one
the second is cost uncertainty
it's hard to estimate how much your
cloud system will cost when it's exposed
to real workload and traffic oh yeah
i've heard that from developers too and
what's your solution i'll tell all
customers set up alerts on budget whose
estimated with a cost calculator
that's why
they get an email if their cloud bill
goes above a certain threshold
however many of my customers have gone
serverless that's magic for them that
scale up and down automatically
but they're also the feeling of losing
control of cost right and what can be
done about that
in cadron you can set the maximum number
of instances
so for example
regardless of traffic they will never
pay for more than 10 cloud instances
and you can put these limits on several
other serverless products like dataflow
or bitcoin
got it and what's the third challenge
you've seen businesses run into when
when they migrate to the cloud yeah the
third one is trust
everyone as a customer has to trust the
cloud creator it's easy when your
systems are in your own data centers you
trust your own servers hydrides
monitoring systems
and when you know the teams in charge of
your data centers and how do you address
that trust challenge
businesses have to ask the stem cell can
my cloud provider and all servers better
than i can
or as well as me but for less
yeah that's why businesses want to move
to the cloud in the first place right
right right smart companies want to
delegate i.t to a club provider to save
money and to be more efficient
they want to focus their teams and money
on their core business
but it takes time to gain trust
and it's not a matter of company size or
move to club budget
it depends more on how well the system
is
the older it is the harder it will be to
gain confidence in the cloud
one good way is to run a pilot project
to migrate one small non-critical system
to the cloud
and when your customers run these pilot
projects how does it usually work out
in fact most of them want to be
cognitive to use only manage and
serverless products or to use containers
and communities
however
it's a big step to train the teams in
serverless or communities
you need many small steps before that
like setting up your cicd pipeline and
putting your applications in contact
csd pipelines and containers those are
big topics how can they get started
i'll tell them to start by performing a
lift and cheat migration
move one of their existing application
as is to the cloud
as they do that they learn what's worked
well in the cloud
and they are in a better place with an
existing app to set up ccd and modernize
with serverless or kubernetes
and why should i start using cscd and
serverless or kubernetes
oh
they can ship code faster reduce so many
errors and optimize cost
dura and the google cloud white paper
describe
the return on investment of devops
transformation
and how to do it
have a look at it
sounds good thanks for sharing your
hard-won experience with us today
guillaume
if you have any questions for guillaume
or me please enter them in the comments
below also please let me know if there
are any other topics you'd like us to
bring up on the show
until next time
[Music]
you